les chers amis je vais vous parlé avec
beaucoup de franchise et avec beaucoup
de clarté
lorsque je suis devenu président de
notre mouvement
à la fin du mois de novembre de l'année
dernière j'ai pu constater la profondeur
de nos divisions et l'incapacité qui
était la nôtre
à l'époque n'ont pas discuté ensemble
mais même à nous rassembler à nous
entendre
je fais de la politique depuis plus de
trente ans jamais je n'avais vu la
famille dans une telle situation de
détestation de tous par tous par tous
les militants les adhérents me disait
on a même aujourd'hui de la peine à dire
qu'on les militants de la famille
l'opposition n'existait plus la place
était laissée immense au front national
pour s'opposer un pouvoir socialiste qui
méthodiquement détruisaient tout ce que
nous avions essayé de construire
il a fallu apaisé il a fallu
reconstruire
il a fallu rassembler je peux vous dire
une chose
ça n'a pas été facile
ce fut un long chemin qui a mis à
contribution
une patience dont je mignerey avoir la
capacité g déstabiliser
un certain nombre d'entre vous un
médecin de saint-etienne l'a écrit sarko
je vous aime je vous reconnais plus vous
ne voyez plus vous n'entendez plus je me
demande même si vous comprenez rassurez
vous mes chers amis je vois tout
j'entends tout et même parfois se
comprend tout mais j'ai fait mon choix
et je ne le regrette pas d'avoir des
problèmes d'audition d'avoir des
problèmes de vision
parce qu'il fallait apaiser reconstruire
rassembler pourquoi pour que chacun
retrouve confiance dans sa famille
politique
la confiance on y attache aucune
importance lorsque l'on a mais quand
elle part la confiance dans une famille
dans un couple dans une organisation
politique on se rend compte que sans
confiance
rien absolument rien n'est possible
conformément aux engagements que j'avais
pris on a tout changé
on a changé de nom à l'origine mes
propres amis me disaient non non non ne
change pas de nom le conservatisme fait
que les militants ne voudront pas 84%
d'entre eux ont dit oui nous nous
appellerons désormais les républicains
qui peut me dire aujourd'hui que le nom
les républicains n'est pas adaptée à la
situation de la france nous avons changé
le statut
on m'a expliqué
mais nicolas tu rassembles et tu vas /
car à des élections
non c'est l'absence d'élections qui
divise c'est l'absence de démocratie qui
divise c'est lorsqu'on force la main des
adhérents qu'ils se sentent alors non
respectés par la direction du mouvement
on a changé notre équipe dirigeante
aujourd'hui comme l'a dit eric ciotti
240 mille militants jour de cotisation
mais nous sommes les seuls à avoir fait
venir un huissier de justice pour
constater que ces chiffres sont les
vrais nous avons gagné les
départementales
roger a eu raison que n'ai-je entendu
avant le premier tour
dix départements devaient être perdu
pour front national à l'arrivée aucun
département pour le front national
c'est grâce à l'action de l'ump de
l'époque et des républicains
d'aujourd'hui
il a fallu avoir les régionales je veux
dire un mot régionaux d'abord pour
féliciter tous nos candidats têtes de
liste et tous nos candidats qui ont fait
campagne dans un climat épouvantable
parce qu'il y avait eu le drame des
attentats du mois de novembre qui ont
fait suite au drame des attentats du
mois de janvier
et j'admire nos candidats qui ont mené
campagne avec une fois une énergie
extraordinaire malgré le contexte et
avec dignité
pourquoi j'admire nos candidats
parce que pour nous les républicains
lorsqu'on monte sur le ring électorale
on se bat contre la gauche et on se bat
contre l'extrême droite
sans compter tous les autres parfois
même de notre propre famille politique
quand on gagne nous
ça a une saveur particulière parce qu'on
gagne contre le front national parce
qu'on gagne contre le parti socialiste
parce qu'on gagne contre une partie des
observateurs qui voudrait tellement
qu'on perde
voilà pourquoi notre victoire n'a pas la
même saveur pour nous que pour les
autres je n'y avais pas besoin d'être
fort n'a rythme éthique avant les
régionales c'est un rejet n'y avait pas
besoin de savoir compter sur les doigts
on avait une région à l'arrivée nous
avons près des deux tiers avec notamment
ce magnifique succès de valérie pécresse
en région parisienne et de laurent
wauquiez dans la région rhône alpes
auvergne
on m'a dit oui jeu magnifique succès que
vous avez eue en pack avec christian
estrosi et dans le nord
pas de calais picardie avec xavier
bertrand qui nous ont apporté deux
magnifiques victoires
les socialistes sont retirés oui mais
ils se sont retirés parce qu'ils ont
fait un score si faible au premier tour
que les électeurs de ces deux régions ne
voulais pas qu'il soit présent au
deuxième tour pour participer à la
bataille
voilà la vérité on a gagné et là encore
il n'y a pas eu de victoire pour le
front national
ça c'était 2015 début 2016
nous avons fait les élections internes
mes chers amis je vous demande d'avoir
un minimum de mémoire ces élections
internes se sont déroulés cher eric
ciotti cher eric woerth dans un climat
qui fait que nulle part dans la presse
je n'ai vu l'expression de la moindre
tension où je n'ai vu la moindre
contestation pour tricherie
ça a toujours été comme ça les élections
dans notre famille on peut se permettre
de se présenter aux élections sans qu'il
en ait des pages et des pages dans la
presse parce que ça c'est fait
honnêtement cela s'est fait avec une
organisation et une transparence comme
cela se fera cher michel cher luc ce
matin vous imaginez ce que cela signifie
une famille politique forte qui parce
qu'elle est forte que choisir et peu des
bacs
alors maintenant c'est 2016 l'année 2016
et en tant que président élu notre
mouvement c'est à moi qu'il revient de
fixer la ligne politique de vouloir
soumettre
ce doit être l'année de la clarté la
gravité de la situation de notre pays
beaucoup plus graves qu'on ne le dit
l'exigence de nos électeurs d'une
alternance franche forte nous en fait
l'obligation
vous venez d'être élu votre légitimité
est incontestable
nous allons donc débattre en profondeur
de questions qui n'ont pas été tranchées
dans le souci légitime de compromis
qu'il nous fallait accepter pour
reconstruire notre famille politique il
est venu le temps pour le conseil
national de dire avec franchise et
clarté qui sommes nous et que
voulons-nous pour la france nous les
républicains aucun sujet vous m'entendez
aucun sujet ne doit être tabou
la parole doit être libre nous devons
aller au fond des choses
la division mais jamais la conséquence
de débat y compris lorsqu'ils sont à
brut
la division est attisée par le faux
unanimisme et les compromis bancal
voilà la ligne politique pour 2016 je
veux donc vous proposer de commencer
aujourd'hui ce travail
tous nos comités départementaux auront à
discuter et à enrichir un texte que je
proposerai à l'issue de nos échanges
demain le bureau politique fera la
synthèse des amendements qui nous
remonterons des comités départementaux
et tous nos adhérents vous m'entendez
tous nos adhérents auront à se prononcer
par un vote sur l'adoption d'un texte
définitif au mois d'avril
je m'étais engagé
et je ne m'engage jamais à la légère a
donné une culture démocratique à ce
mouvement
pour moi ce ne sont pas des mots la
politique c'est trop souvent des mots
pas assez des faits on ne dirige pas une
formation politique en 2016
comme on pouvait le faire il y a vingt
ans après le choix des personnes nos
adhérents ont approché les choix de
ligne politique
le but de cet exercice ne consiste pas à
adopter un programme de gouvernement qui
viendra en son temps c'est à dire au
printemps le but de l'exercice que je
vous demande et que nous commençons
aujourd'hui c'est de clarifier notre
philosophie politique et de préciser nos
orientations stratégiques sur le fond
comme sur la forme
je présenterai donc demain un texte qui
n'engagera pas ce qu'un président élu
c'est un président qui s'engage ici
c'est la cinquième république
c'est pas la quatrième république et
dans la vème république le président il
a des convictions is back sur ses
convictions je prendrai des
responsabilités et vous ne serez pas
déçus quelle place accorde non à la
nation dans notre projet devons-nous
adopté un projet collectif
indépendamment des primaires ou
devons-nous attendre que les candidats
aux primaires daigne nous proposer leurs
idées
un parti politique son projet collectif
n'est pas un parti politique c'est un
club de supporters
voilà pourquoi je veux un projet
collectif fort pour la formation
politique qui est la nôtre
quel choix faisons-nous sur l'autorité
de l'état sur l'immigration sur la
fiscalité
quelle est notre position sur le front
national est sûre parti socialiste moi
je vais vous dire une chose
parfois je suis lassé d'entendre à
longueur de radio et télévision
certains d'entre nous donner leur avis
sur un sujet sans que la majorité du
mouvement ne puisse exprimer son choix
collectifs gare à une position pas 50
position sur ces questions
les français sont à juste titre
préoccupé l'alternance elle repose sur
nos épaules
la stratégie pour l'alternance pour moi
aller simple tout dire avant l'élection
tout dire avant pour tout faire après
tout ce qui n'aura pas été dit avant ne
pourra pas être fait après l'échec du
quinquennat de monsieur hollande est
inscrit dans la faute qu'il a commise au
moment de la campagne présidentielle de
quand on ment pendant la campagne
présidentielle on ne peut pas appliquer
une politique pour la france
voilà la leçon que nous donne
inverse monsieur hollande mes chers amis
face au spectacle d'impuissance que nous
donne ce gouvernement navigue entre la
petite arithmétique médiocre d'un
remaniement fait arrangements
politiciens et l'incapacité totale à
porter une parole et inaction
est-ce que franchement le président
n'avait pas autre chose à faire que ce
romain ce remaniement
avec le chômage qui explose avec la
menace terroriste si présente avec
l'inquiétude de tous les français mais
nous ça nous fait peser et je terminerai
par là une responsabilité particulière
le spectacle ce remaniement raté
nous devons y répondre par l'image de ce
conseil national portant une
responsabilité inédite rassemblé libre
travailleurs sérieux parce que quand on
est travailleur et sérieux
on impose l'idée de la confiance que
l'on ne peut nous faire et nous devons
chacun d'entre nous et vous verrez que
j'ai veillé à ce que tous ceux qui
souhaitent prendre la parole puisque
d'apprendre soyons attentifs à l'image
que nous donnons notre famille politique
j'aime votre capacité d'écouté je n'aime
pas quand le parlement du mouvement se
dispersent et n'écoute pas au prétexte
qu'il n'est pas d'accord quand vous
n'êtes pas d'accord écouter encore mieux
parce que c'est comme ça que vous
donnerez ou français le visage d'hommes
et de femmes qui respecte les autres
les français attendent de nous l'esprit
de responsabilité et nous sont jugés
tout au long de ces deux jours sur cet
esprit de responsabilité
cela veut dire mes chers amis pas de
polémiques futiles
donnez votre opinion
faites partager votre idéal pas
d'affrontement stérile les primaires
viendront en leur temps
7 ans 9 ans on est fort quand on est
fort par soi même pas parce qu'on
critique sa propre famille politique ou
ceux qui éventuellement seraient les
concurrents dans l'éphémère et cher ami
et je sais que beaucoup partagent ce
point de vue n'est ce pas bruno n'est ce
pas jean pierre nous ne sommes pas le
parti socialiste et nous ne voulons pas
ressembler au parti socialiste qui n'ai
fait que deux chapelles de division de
combines et d'affrontement débattre
librement se respecte est tout
simplement nous appartenons à la même
famille une famille que nous avons fait
renaître
nous sommes tous les républicains je
vous demande de vous habituer à réserver
vos critiques et parfois même aux
sifflets à nos adversaires politiques
il n'y a pas d'adversaires politiques
dans cette salle il n'y a que des amis
que nous allons écouter entendre et
respecter et parce que nous nous
respecterons les français nous suivrons
merci à vous